hi I'm Eric Voss and Avengers infinity
warhead something no other Marvel
Studios movie did before an indie that
kind of scared us yes in this video I
will talk about the ending of infinity
war so if you haven't seen the movie the
boiler warning dove okay let's clear up
some of the questions that you might
have had about the ending of this movie
what it all means and what's the deeper
meaning of this movie the final moments
of infinity war show Thanos acquiring
all six Infinity stones and despite Thor
impaling his chest with his new hammer
Stormbreaker Thanos snaps his fingers in
the world goes blank the aftermath shows
half of everyone we know fading into
dust
leaving the survivors stunned and all of
us in tears so first and foremost how
did thinners do this so as we know
wiping out half the universe has always
been famous his primary goal he first
acquired the power stone he destroyed
Xander before the events of the movie
power stone basically makes him
invincible in battle that helped him get
the space stone from Loki on the
Asgardian ship the space stone allows
him to create rifts and space and zip
anywhere in the universe
one of those places was nowhere where he
got the reality stone from the collector
that also happened off screen reality
stone allows him to manipulate the
reality around everyone and like turn
people into ribbon and whatnot while in
know where he ran into Gamora
who helped him find the soul stone which
he got by sacrificing Gamora on Baumer
the soul stone appears to connect Thanos
with all the souls in the universe but
we'll get more into what exactly that
stone does in another video Vanis had
planned for his Black Order lieutenants
to get the other two soul stones which
is why he returned to Titan
unfortunately that failed so we got
ambushed but the Avengers failed in this
battle so we got the time stone from
Doctor Strange who gave it to him in
exchange for sparing Tony starts life
we'll also talk more about why Doctor
Strange might have done that in another
video the time stone allows Thanos to
rewind time the way Doctor Strange did
against her mama he or Thanos uses it to
rewind before Scarlett which destroys
visions mind stone so that he can rip it
out of visions forehead so that mine
stone I assume gives that us all the
divine insight that vision had but more
importantly completes the mystic power
that all the six stones have together
and thanks to these special gauntlet
forged by Peter Dinklage's character
Thanos can wield all six together and do
literally anything he wants in this case
snap half of everyone out of existence
so that leads us to the next question
who died and who survived let's break
all that down
Loki
Heimdall Gamora envision fully died in
this movie before the snap even happened
though it is possible that sure he could
have uploaded visions consciousness onto
her server or something like that but he
seemed pretty dead in those final scenes
as for the characters who fade in a dust
in the snap wave there was black panther
spider-man Scarlet Witch Bucky dr.
strange Falcon star-lord Drax Groot
mantis and then the post-credits scene
Nick Fury and Maria hill now that
doesn't necessarily mean these faders
are dead permanently Marvel already has
more spider-man movies in the works
they're probably also planning sequels
to Black Panther and guardians of the
galaxy and Doctor Strange because why
wouldn't they there are quite a few
different ways these characters could be
brought back use the time stone for wine
time even further or easing the reality
stone to maybe switch over to another
reality where they're still alive
actually go check out our other video
for some more theories on that but let's
talk about the survivors Iron Man
Captain America Thor Bruce Banner Black
Widow war machine nebula rocket Ocoee
and mbaku Sheree and Wong are likely
still here with us and of course Hawkeye
ant-man and the wasp they weren't in
this movie but hopefully they're still
around why were all these Avengers left
alive while the others turn in a dust
now it's probably not a coincidence that
the original six from the first Avengers
movie were left alive for the final
battle with Thanos in Avengers 4 earlier
in the movie Doctor Strange actually
told stark that he saw 14 million
different futures and that only one was
a path to victory that one must have
required Tony Stark to survive this I
think for the next movie Marvel wants
the og heroes to lead the charge
benching all the newer heroes for now
and like Stark I think there will be a
specific reason for each of these
survivals for example rocket Ocoee a
Sheree and Wong are all kind of
representatives from their sides of the
MCU and nebula might have been spared
because in the Infinity Gauntlet comics
she is actually the one to initially
disarm Thanos of the gauntlet and use it
to reset the timeline
we'll see if the final movie ends up
going in that direction but one of the
other big questions was where did the
nose go the moment he snapped his
fingers now we briefly saw him enter
this orange colored realm with a young
Gamora
under the gate from her homeworld she
asks Thanos what did it cost and Danis
responds
everything now Thanos could be inside of
these soulstone here remember he had to
sacrifice Gamora to get that soul stone
and it has a similar orange color tone
in the comics the soul stone is
associated with a soul worlds type realm
and this could be some version of that
one interesting possible implication of
this is that Thanos might have been
among the half of the universe that got
wiped out like he might have actually
died here and that only through the soul
stone was he able to come back really
the overall question is why why didn't
finnaly war have to end so dark like
this structurally speaking infinity war
plays a similar role in the avengers
saga that the empire strikes back to two
star wars or some of the later harry
potter chapters did before the final
Deathly Hallows movie if you remember
those penultimate chapters had
incredibly bleak shocking endings
featuring the heroes beaten down to
their deepest rock bottoms one of the
main criticisms some people are making
about infinity war and that they made
for many of the MCU team ups that
preceded it was that there were just
simply too many characters and
storylines for us to be emotionally
attached to any one of them so in a
sense Marvel's greatest drawback became
its greatest strengths by wiping out
half of these beloved figures it gives
us a shocking catharsis while also
fixing the overcrowding problem for the
final showdown this actually helps us
empathize with Thanos recontextualizing
him as the movie's protagonist the final
frame shows his somewhat satisfied smile
but his emotions are really mixed here
he's still not really sure whether his
goal was worth the sacrifice we two have
many of these mixed emotions creating a
need for resolution that the final
chapter will hopefully bring next year I
know you will probably have a lot of
other questions so comment with those
questions down below and stay tuned for
a lot more videos on this channel to
address those mysteries and of course a
massive except breakdown for all the
cool details that you might have missed
coming out this week you can tweet me
directly at us and of course like and
share this video and subscribe to new
rock stars for all of our infinity war
videos thanks for watching guys bye